- So, Charlize and Kerry, the two of you,
you're an elite group
of women in Hollywood,
like, people love you,
love everything you do.
(audience cheers)
And you do such huge
films, the both of you.
We know you like so well. TV, everything.
So, what made you gravitate
towards this project?
- Well, I am a single
mom to two little girls.
Seven and ten. And my repertoire's
quite dark. (laughter)
- [Kelly] "Monster"? What? (laughs)
- Yeah. Yeah.
- They didn't like that?
- I have a feeling they'd have to be
at least 52 to see any
of my work. (laughter)
So there's a lot of mystery.
There's like, "Why do we see Mom on a set,
and she's always covered in blood?"
So this felt like I could do something
that's a little bit of a love
letter to them, you know?
And -
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- They saw it with me in
Rome, a couple of weeks ago.
Oh my God. Like, you know,
I'm gonna be 50 soon.
And I was like, I thought I
was jaded and dead inside.
Like I wanted their approval so badly.
It was almost, I had to re-watch the movie
'cause I'd barely watched it.
I was just watching their faces.
- Yeah, their reaction. Yeah.
- Yeah. So I really
wanted to do something.
I also, I really love Paul.
I had worked with Paul.
I was lucky enough to work
with Paul a couple years ago.
And had such a great experience with him.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And then this cast and
the story, was really,
it was a big world, and fun,
and we were all coming out of lockdown.
So I think we were just,
this felt like such a gift.
To be able to go and
play in these costumes,
coming out of COVID.
- Yeah. It's so cool. It is funny.
'Cause I have two kids,
too. I'm a single mom too.
And it is funny. All that you do,
it's so funny what counts to them.
- Yeah.
- Yes.
- Like, you're like, wait,
I've done like some really cool stuff.
- [Charlize] Most of it,
they don't care about.
- They don't care. I know
they're impressed by the -
But of course they're impressed by this.
And what cool thing to be
a part of, like a series.